Hi, welcome back.
In this session I'd like to talk about
trading on information, buying or
selling based on information.
Wall Street is full of these little
adages, buy on the rumor, sell on the
news. Is that true?
So to set the foundation for what we're
going to do in this session, let's think
about what information is and how this
process plays out.
When you track a stock in the market,
you have investors holding the stock and
new information comes out about the
stock. It could be an earnings report, a
rumor about a stock, a management
change.
Investors attempt to assess the effect
on price  value based on that
information.
Now that assessment can be different for
different investors. Why? Because the
information they receive can actually be
different. That might not be the case
with an earnings report, but it could be
the case with a rumor. And the way they
process that same information,
a thousand investors can look at the
same earnings report and come to a
thousand different conclusions about
that. The ultimate price change will
depend on demand and supply.
It's a messy process, right? Information
comes in, investors try to reassess,
sometimes they get it right, sometimes
they get it wrong.
So let's think broadly about the
different ways in which information play
out in the market.
If you live in a truly efficient market,
should prices change? Yes, when new
information comes out, but they should
change instantaneously.
So that's if If you get new good news
about a stock
or a company, the stock price should pop
up to reflect that good news, but then
it should level off.
So in an efficient market, there will be
price changes, but they will be
instantaneous
as the information is revealed.
If you have a slow learning market,
here's what will happen.
Information comes out, it's still good
news. Investors push up the price a
little, but they're not quite done.
Other investors take more time. So, over
time the price will drift up
to what it should be. How long that
drift last can vary depending on how
efficient the market is. It could be in
5 minutes, 10 minutes, or it could take
5 days to do this.
That's a slow learning market.
What if you have an overreacting market?
The good news comes out, the price pops,
but it pops up too much. It goes up too
much.
And because it goes up too much in the
days or the hours or the minutes after
the price will drift down.
The keyword is drift. In an efficient
market, there should be no price drift.
In a market that's not quite efficient
in assessing information, there can be
price drifts up if it's a slow learning
market or price drifts down
if it's an overreacting market on good
news, and the reverse is going to be
true on bad news.
So, if you want to trade on information,
you need to start by making a judgment
on which of these three views of the
world you adopt when it comes to
information.
Cuz there are broadly three strategies
you can use for trading on information.
The first is you can trade ahead of the
news.
If you can pull this off, this has the
biggest upside. What does this mean?
Before an earnings report comes out, you
start buying companies where you think
the earnings announcement is going to
contain good news. How do you know that?
You do research. You come up with your
own way of doing it. We'll talk about
different ways you might get that
assessment.
But you buy it before And when the
earnings report comes out, assuming you
were right and the earnings report is
good news, you get the jump in the
price, trading ahead of the news.
You can trade on the news. The earnings
report comes out, you buy the stock
instantaneously if it's good news,
hoping to take advantage of it. Or you
sell the short
stock in And which one you do will
depend on whether you think, you know,
the the effect is going to be, you know,
is is fully played out or whether
there's going to be a drift.
And you could even do this on volatility
changing.
Or you could trade after the news.
Yeah.
What does that mean? You wait a day
after the earnings report and you try to
take advantage of that continuing drift
in either direction.
Buying or selling on that drift. You can
trade ahead of the news, on the news, or
after the news. Let's take a look at
each of those different types of
information trading strategies.
First, ahead of the news.
How do you make an assessment that that
news report that's not due to come out a
week from now is going to contain good
news or bad news?
There's one way, which is probably
illegal in the US and in much of the
world, which is you have inside
information.
And let's face it.
I know I'm cynical on this. Insider
information exists. People trade on it.
There's going to be a drift ahead of
good news
or bad news. Insider or private
information.
The second is rumor mills. There's
rumors all the time about companies. The
problem is most of them are false, but
perhaps you have a good a source of good
rumors. Rumors that actually have basis.
That might be a way.
Or you could do research. Maybe you come
up with a way of forecasting which types
of companies are going to report
good earnings.
Insider information, rumor, or research.
Now, how you trade on this will depend
on how reliable
that in- that news source is, right? To
the extent that you're trading on a
rumor and the rumor is very speculative,
you got to hold back a lot more than if
you're trading on inside information
that is guaranteed.
And your investment strategy will also
depend on on not only will it when you
trade depend, but how much you trade and
how big the trade can be will also
depend on the reliability of the
strategy.
So, those are the things that you can
use to trade ahead of the news.
What about on the news? You can trade on
the immediate price reaction.
Good news comes out about a company, the
price jumps, you might decide the price
jump was too much and you sell the
stock. Or the price jump was too little
and you buy the stock. You're taking
advantage of the drift that's going to
come if you're right after the
announcement.
But you can also trade on volatility.
You think, "What does that mean?"
Over the last 40 years, there have been
instruments that have been created that
are less about the level of the price
and more proxies for volatility.
In the In the overall market, this can
take the form of the VIX. The VIX is
actually an index on equity market
volatility.
And what you're trading on is that the
level of volatility itself might change
over time.
So, news comes out,
it can affect not just the the price
level, but the volatility in the stock.
The stock could get riskier or safer.
And you're making an assessment in
whether the volatility that the market
is building in is just right.
So, let's take an example.
Let's suppose an earnings report comes
out that reveals that this company is
entering riskier businesses.
Well, that's going to increase the
volatility in the company, right?
You go to the market and option prices
have gone up to reflect, but they've
gone up too much. In other words, the
market has overestimated how much
volatility should change and you're
trading on that volatility.
So, whether it's using options or direct
instruments on volatility, you're trying
to take advantage of shifts in
volatility that you think are either too
low or too high given the information.
So, in addition to trading on the level
of the price, you're trading on the
volatility in the price.
That's on the news.
What about afterwards?
There, the judgment that you made about
whether markets are slow to learn or
overreacting come into play. If it's a
slow learning market, here's what you're
going to do. You're going to buy after
good news. You're going to sell after
bad news. You see why, right? Cuz you
buy after good news, the drift continues
to be positive, you make money on it.
You sell after bad news, it's a drift
down
on which you make money as well.
If you have an overreacting market, you
reverse the strategy. You sell after
good news because you think markets
overreact, there'll be a drift down,
and you buy after bad news.
In both cases, not only do you have need
to get the timing of when you buy or
sell right, you got to get the timing of
when you exit your strategy also right,
but
So, you can trade on the news, you can
trade before the news, you can trade
after the news. Now, all of this,
execution becomes a much more critical
part of your strategy. Unlike
traditional value or growth investing
where we did not talk much about
execution, when you have an
information-based strategy, it matters
when you trade and how quickly you trade
and how low your and how low or high
your transactions costs are. So, you
have to make judgments about the
execution part.
And the transactions costs will come
with that strategy. With an information
trading strategy, if you're not careful,
you might make money before transactions
costs,
but very quickly wipe them out with your
trading costs.
And if your information is coming from
that gray area between inside
information that's illegal and private
information that's legal,
you got to make sure you're on the right
side of the line. Cuz that's a different
kind of risk, a risk you might end up in
jail cuz you used information you
shouldn't have used to trade.
So, let's summarize.
An information event is a news story
either about the company, the market,
the sector that can move prices.
In information-based trading strategies,
you start with the presumption that
markets don't always react the right
way, right way in terms of adjusting
prices to information, and you're going
to try to exploit those mistakes to make
money for yourself.
Now having said all of that this session
has been pretty abstract because we
haven't actually defined individual
information events. In the next few
sessions we're going to talk about
earnings reports, insider trading
filings, you know,
the acquisition announcements,
management changes, the kinds of news
stories that hit markets and look at
what the evidence shows about about how
well or badly markets do in responding
to those new that news.
Thank you very much for listening.